one two great stuff
I'm a cheetah matchmaker I actively
manage a stud book for cheetah in 53
different reserves across the country so
I effectively identify which cheetah are
related to each other to swap
individuals between these reserves to
prevent inbreeding there we go we prefer
natural gene flow but the landscape has
been transformed by human activities
it's no longer possible for cheetah to
traverse the landscape the vets got his
start gun ready and he's going to fire
away it's then that you realize things
are even going to go well now or they're
gonna go pear-shaped
[Music]
it takes them a good five minutes to go
down and in that period they can cover a
fair amount of distance it's often quite
tricky to located especially at this
thick bush but once we've immobilized a
cheetah we've got about 40 minutes to do
a various amounts of work to obtain
genetic material funding nice mucus over
there we then put the animals into
relocation and crates especially
designed to prevent the cheetah
hopping around too much I must be honest
I still go through bouts of nervousness
we've learned that it's not easy to
relocate while lab a very stressed we
need to move
look at that event locals you're not
getting mad we prefer to release in
daylight so that animal doesn't run into
the fence lines and fence posts during
emergencies we sometimes have to make
the hard call of releasing at night
if you start joining two sides of the
vomer then we'll be left option but to
immobilize him again will not be ideal
but the last thing I wanna do is lays
this cat don't think we must have you
guys there
sorry first thing we wanted to do turn
around and run five s
nice relaxed the very best moment for me
in this job is when you get that phone
call from the reserve manager saying
Vincent we've got four new clubs that
were born to the cheetah that you bought
in here six months ago that is what
really brings joy to my heart although
they mean to us parting is about to
scream I was hyperventilating
almost